bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
en direct sur figaro life pour cette
émission consacrée aux conflits de
voisinage un sujet qui nous concerne
tous et pour lequel vous avez
certainement des témoignages ou des
questions à nous loue à nous poser à
nous livrer alors vous n'hésitez pas à
nous solliciter nous sommes avec vous
pendant une heure pour vous répondre
en présence d'un expert et en
l'occurrence jean philippe mariani qui
est à mes côtés bonjour monsieur mariani
pour jour merci merci à vous d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
alors quand on parle de conflits de
voisinage on pense aux causes qui les
ont déclenchés évidemment le bruit un
vis-à-vis trop présent des animaux trop
bruyant des plantations trop
envahissante par exemple dans cette
liste de cause que j'ai cités quelle est
celle jean philippe mariani qui revient
le plus souvent dans les litiges que
vous et vos confrères gérer je dirais le
bruit c'est le bruit le bruit c'est le
le plus facile je dirais à mettre en
oeuvre puisque vous avez quand même
encore beaucoup de constructions
anciennes qui ne sont pas qui ne
respectent pas les normes phoniques
d'aujourd'hui est donc là c'est assez
facile de créer des nuisances sans même
avoir forcément un comportement vraiment
anormal mais voilà le puits après il ya
les sensibilités le bruit c'est aussi
très très sujets d'histoire de
perception et de valeurs et de nos joies
y avait l'histoire de la chaussure de la
deuxième chaussure
c'est quoi cette histoire de la ville de
fès et leurs voisins ils tous les soirs
en retard fait du bruit et il balance
ses chaussures une chaussure de
chaussures donc le voisin du dessous
valoir en lui disant vous pourriez
arrêter de balancer vos chaussures la
nuit suivant il fait il balance sa
première chaussure qui résultent
mon voisin il retient la deuxième il va
voir le voisin lendemain il lui dit j'ai
pas dormi de la nuit j'ai attendu la
deuxième chaussure
c'est une anecdote assez sympa mais le
bruit est donc la première mise en ce
qui entraîne des conflits de voisinage
vient de me dire jean philippe mariani
qui est avec nous ce soir pendant une
heure pour répondre à toutes vos
questions
analysez vos témoignages en rapport avec
les conflits de voisinage que vous
et où que vous êtes en train de
d'essayer de résoudre
alors si vous avez des exemples des
témoignages ou des questions vous
n'hésitez pas à nous en faire part sur
le chat du figaro et sur youtube et la
chaîne youtube de figaro live que dit la
loi
jean philippe mariani à propos du
conflit de voisinage à partir de quel
moment
la loi considère tel qu'il y a un
trouble du voisinage
mais la loi ne dit rien c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire le législateur a un peu
de mal à s'intéresser où il a peur à ces
à ces histoires du quotidien et en fait
c'est la jurisprudence
ce sont les juges qui ont été amenés en
détournant un petit peu un texte sur sur
la propriété puisque le texte dit qu'on
peut user de sa propriété dans le
respect de la loi et du règlement et les
juges sont venus dire bah oui du coup ça
va cette liberté d' usage de la
propriété elle va s'arrêter au trouble
anormal de jouissance au trouble anormal
de voisinage
c'est un domaine où on parle de la
théorie de la trouble de la théorie du
trouble anormal de voisinage qui a été
totalement créé par la jurisprudence est
donc en fait c'est vraiment quand ça se
passe quand il ya un procès quand il ya
des conflits à résoudre c'est dû
vraiment du cas par cas
on va dire totalement totalement c'est
la difficulté majeure pour l'avocat
puisque il doit apprécier les éléments
de preuve
quelquefois on doit avoir recours à des
expertises matière de bruit notamment
les constats qui sont faits sur place au
moment où les événements ce cas là il ya
des constats d'huissiers qui sont chères
il ya aussi le système qui fonctionne
bien de capteurs on installe par un
professionnel un capteur qui va pouvoir
enregistrer pendant 15 jours les
différents niveaux de bruit qui va
mesurer la différence parce que le bruit
c'est effectivement une perception et
c'est aussi une différence par rapport à
aux bruits ambiants donc qu'ils vont
mesurer les bruits pendant la journée la
nuit et là on va avoir sur quinze jours
trois semaines des éléments
d'appréciation
la voilà on a d'énormes quand même
qu'ils se mettent en place et donc c'est
le nombre des décibels en rapport avec
allo des six mais la fréquence le côté
brutal non répétitif parce qu'on peut
s'habituer à des à des bruits on peut
s'habituer à un niveau sonore on
s'habitue la noce au nord en revanche
les ruptures et les bruits nocturnes
sont beaucoup plus pénalisant on y
reviendra au bruit nocturne dans
quelques minutes avec vous jean philippe
mariani
j'aimerais qu'on comprenne et qu'on
apprenne un peu à gérer un conflit de
voisinage est ce qu'il ya des étapes à
suivre quand ces conflits naissent pour
éviter que ça dégénère on va dire
absolument bah ça c'est un domaine à des
expertises qui est assez récente puisque
je me suis formé il ya quatre ans au
modèle viable je retournais à
l'université à prendre ce comment on
gérait les modèles viables j'étais
spécialiste en droit immobilier depuis
longtemps donc j'avais la réponse
judiciaire qui n'est pas parfaite on y
reviendra
et comme j'étais de nature assez
conciliatrice que j'aimais bien
rechercher des accords
voilà je venais comme ça dans cette
formation chercher un peu une
certification et j'ai découvert tout un
univers sur ce qu'il ya des gens qui
réfléchissent et qu'ils ont déjà
théorisé la mécanique du conflit et la
voilà un avocat qui pourtant en pratique
le conflit depuis 30 ans découvre sous
continent il ya des mécaniques il y à
des mécaniques de fonctionnement du
cerveau auquel on ne peut pas échapper
et alors le domaine de l'immobilier du
voisinage est pas encore identifié comme
étant un des domaines porteurs du mode
amiable on pense tout de suite au droit
de la famille c'est vrai que c'est là
que modèle viable s'est implanté on
pense au droit du travail et pas
forcément ou dans l'immobilier pourtant
droit immobilier c'est quand même
l'appartement le territoire intime et
c'est un domaine concerne le quotidien
la sécurité on rentre chez soi on voit
là on est à l'extérieur même des pions
le soir on rentre chez soi est rentré
chez soi avec comme on vit la boule au
ventre avec ce qu'il est là est ce qu'il
va me croiser qu'est ce qui va se passer
etc
c'est extrêmement destructeur donc c'est
vrai que c'est pour moi un terrain où il
faut vraiment courrier de la pédagogie
et qu'on apprenne parce que on se met
très facilement en colère on se met très
facilement en colère
or parfois le sentiment que l'autre en
face le fait exprès pour nous embêter
alors que parfois c'est juste un
malentendu
voilà ça c'est typique de la mécanique
du conflit on diabolise l'autre on est
persuadé que forcément il ya un manque
de respect de sa part il ya une volonté
de nuire
alors qu'en réalité l'autre est dans sa
bulle et quand on est dans son propre
comportement et que l'autre bien voilà
moi il ya un an voisin du dessous et une
borne va vous jouer de la guitare à 8
heures du matin
moi je travaille j'aime bien faire la
grasse matinée je vais absolument pas
l'impression d'un des généraux 8h 9h on
sait pas une guitare électrique je
rassure bon ben c'est vrai qu'on le vit
mal quand on vous remet en cause et
après ça pendant un mois ça m'a agacé
parce que justement j'avais décidé de
faire ma guitare de faire mes exercices
à 8 heures du matin
bon j'ai dû m'adapter et puis c'est
passé en fait il a aujourd'hui il a
oublié je joue peut-être plus doucement
vous avez changé au village avec ses
valises et adapter un petit peu à ça
demain mais du coup comment on peut
aider les internautes qui nous regardent
qui sont peut-être en train d'initier
malgré un conflit avec leurs voisins
alors qu'il ne souhaite pas et est ce
qu'il ya des étapes comme je vous le
demande et il ya quelques minutes à
suivre voilà il ya un voisin qui vous
gêne
est ce qu'il faut aller taper à sa porte
est-ce qu'il faut lui envoyer un
courrier est-ce qu'il faut l'aborder en
montrant tout de suite les crocs ou
plutôt y aller de façon diplomatique
est ce qu'il ya des petites astuces
comme ça pour éviter que ça monte en
épingle
effectivement il ya des préconisations
pour pour le modèle viable privilégier
les échanges physiques directes le
courrier le mail est très dangereux
parce que on monte vite en puissance au
monde vite dans les tours on se lâche
lorsqu'on écrit lorsqu'on a un
interlocuteur en face d'abord on mesure
mieux l'impact de ce que de ce qui se
passe on mesure pas toujours l'impact
d'un courrier on al'impression le nombre
de fois où les gens j'ai fait un
courrier très gentil très argumenté elle
n'a pas été perçu comme tel était une
bombe pour pour l'autre partie donc à la
limite quand on parle on
il faut
après il faut choisir ses moments c'est
à dire qu'elle allait taper à la porte
c'est prendre le risque d'arriver au
moment où l'interlocuteur est en train
de faire à manger vient d'apprendre une
mauvaise nouvelle a passé une mauvaise
journée donc on fait une démarche pour
se parler plus tard en disant à quel
moment pour voir à quel moment
pourrions-nous l'échangé et après il ya
tout un travail sur ce qu'on appelle la
communication violente et non violente
et malal faut peut-être se faire aider
si le serbe anatomy mais il pense pas à
l'imaginer à vous êtes en train de
parler d'une une préparation presque
psychologique espèce de coaching pour
pouvoir s'adresser à ses voisins mais
oui mais en même temps si on ne le fait
pas on prend le risque de 2,2 mal de mal
démarrer la la la mécanique il ya un
livre extraordinaire sur sur le modèle
viable je faire de la publicité shenhua
moore pouvez vous pouvez ça s'appelle
les sept grain de lumière dans le coeur
des guerriers et de pierre pélissier
c'est en poche 7 euros 80 g pas j'ai pas
de commission là dessus j'en ai offert
40 a tout mon entourage on sait par ma
mère et mes enfants et ça commence par
des courriers c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire je le passais une
consoeur et un moment je lui dis est-ce
que tu les as lui il m'a dit oui j'ai lu
les courriers sait très bien ce sont des
courriers d'avocat je n'aurais continue
et tu verras que ces courriers d'avocat
bienveillant argumenté taper au coin du
bon sens ils vont finir par une guerre
parce que ce qu'on ne sait pas c'est que
argumenté revendiquer son droit en
réalité chez l'autre c'est vécu comme
une agression si j'argumente sais que tu
te crois plus intelligents que moi et je
contre argumenter et on rentre dans la
mécanique et après c'est difficile mais
c'est assez compliqué c'est difficile
d'éviter le conflit en définitive
regardez on va essayer de répondre un
mari par exemple mari nous a laissé un
commentaire sur twitter et on l'en
remercie parce que on est là pour vous
répondre ce soir
les histoires de conflits de voisinage
tout le monde en a connu on a des
témoignages a donné on a des questions
parfois posées bain marie elle nous
demande mon voisin n'arrête pas de
bloquer ma place de parking avec sa
voiture
je lui ai déjà signalé mais il n'a
jamais rien changé à ses habitudes que
faire qu'est-ce qu'on peut répondre à
marie le précepte delà de la
communication non violente
ces deux noeuds d'éviter le tue
formule c'est le tutu et donc de
formuler sa sa requête non pas vous
empiéter sur ma vous vous comportez mal
et c'est de dire d'exprimer sa
souffrance je suis ennuyé je perdre de
temps je rentre il faut essayer de faire
partager son émotion et sa souffrance en
partant du jeu et puis de passer aussi
parfois au mode qu'on appelle
métalangage c'est à dire je comprends
pas c'est comment l enjeu pour vous
voilà alors il faut tester cette
communication dominante après il ya
aussi des psychopathes et des gens n'ont
pas loin voilà un psychopathe il est un
peu exagéré mais enfin je crois pas trop
aux pervers narcissique en revanche il
ya des personnes qui sont totalement
étanche aux souffrances de l'autre on ça
ça existe
et puis vous avez derrière parce que ça
ce sont des techniques de communication
il ya beaucoup de conflits qui naissent
sur la communication
mais vous avez aussi des conflits de
valeurs et là il faut pouvoir le
détecter mais ce que si l'autre n'a n'a
pas appris à respecter la propriété
là on va avoir un vrai souci parce qu'il
va falloir faire passer le message que
non on peut pas utiliser les parties
communes comme si c'était et mettre
toutes ses poussettes trottinette et
c'est au milieu de l'escalier on peut
pas et qu'une place de parking c'est une
place de parking
donc il faut tester c'est très difficile
quand on est impliqué soi-même dans la
colère
oui pour voir où est le problème chez
l'autre est-ce que voilà ce que est ce
que là dans le cas de marie par exemple
dont le voisin n'arrête pas de bloquer
sa place de parking faut qu'elle fasse
des concessions faut qu'elle accepte en
définitive que est finalement qu elle
accepte d'avoir un voisin qui viennent
embêter dans le mode amiable ça c'est le
parfois le malentendu on du muet parce
que les gens il ya des gens considèrent
on est des gens qui prennent sur eux
j'avais un père qui prenait tout le
temps sur le banc mais est donc ça c'est
bien mais en fait favoriser auprès de
mes gars ont fait du mal et on risque
d'exploser donc c'est important de voir
que choisir le mode amiable ça n'est pas
transiger sur ses propres besoins
il faut que les propres besoins soient
respectées parce que sinon ça se
terminera mal mais par contre il faut
arriver à se détacher de sa souffrance
pendant un premier temps et d'essayer de
voir
une fois chez l'autre à quoi ça
correspond est ce qu'il sait pas conduit
est-ce que voilà c est ce qui rentre le
soir fatigué il faut essayer d'instaurer
le dialogue
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé est ce
que ça a démarré très vite sur un ace
qu'elle a essayé gentiment il n'a pas
écouté donc
et quand on y arrive pas en direct c'est
vrai que il faut essayer de passer par
un tiers hélas un tiers j'allais vous
posez la question on entend souvent
parler de médiateur qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un médiateur comment on trouve une
personne qui peut nous aider ça se il
faut taper sur internet iliad et il ya
des associations de médiateur s'est pas
encore une profession totalement
réglementé mais ça va l'être parce que
là il ya des choses en discussion aux
assemblées et je pense qu'on va voir
apparaître un comité national de
labellisation parce que ça devient un
élément essentiel de résolution des
litiges à un moment où notre justice est
un peu à bout de souffle et donc on il
ya des associations il ya une fédération
française des centres de médiation
donc il ya quand même des diplômes qui
sont qui sont reconnus ou par exemple
chez moi à la mairie de levallois vous
avez une permanence la mairie a eu la
bonne idée il ya des permanences est
avocat et il ya des permanences
médiateur donc je pense que ça ça ce
sont des choses qui vont se généraliser
ont parfois on sait que les comités
d'entreprise pareil assure des
consultations juridiques je pense
qu'elles viendront à à proposer les
services d'un médiateur est donc un
médiateur c'est quelqu'un qui est fort
mais moi je suis moi-même médiateur la
formation que j'ai suivi ma donné la
possibilité de revendiquer ce titre et
c'est quelqu'un qui est formé à ce mode
amiable et qui va essayer d'avoir cette
démarche rétablir la communication
d'abord comprendre les récits voir où
est ce que ça bloque voir si on peut les
rapprocher et une fois qu'on a compris
ou est-ce que ça bloque là on peut
commencer à trouver les solutions mais
le l'échec que l'on il ya deux échecs il
ya deux deux erreurs que l'on commet
facilement c'est la négo rapport de
force mené c'est oui parce que si nab on
tire a passé un activement on se dit si
je suis faible l'autre va marcher dessus
donc il faut que j'apparaisse pas où est
le chat qui se fait aussi gros que le
tigre reste ça ça risque de départ en
échec au match et si on y met
j'allais dire quelque chose de dangereux
mais voilà si votre voisin est un repris
de justice on va pas le qualifier
autrement et que vous savez qu'il est
armé
oui vous allez peut-être recul est
effectivement dans cette hypothèse donc
ça peut marcher mais vous allez trouver
finalement une solution pour le pour le
contre et puis vous avez peut-être le
dénoncer à la police ou faire autre
chose dont nous gérons ministre m
des choses à l'arrière la négo rapporte
de touriste selon que l'on a
instinctivement que l'on souhaite mettre
en oeuvre
elle marche à deux conditions seulement
on a un très très gros pouvoir de
nuisance et de menaces ce qui n'est pas
donné à tout le monde est menacé d'un
procès ce n'est pas toujours efficace et
ensuite le l'enjeu n'est pas vital pour
l'autre même si vous avez un gros
rapport de force si l'enjeu est vital
pour l'homme il vous le fera payer tout
ça très donc été j'ai pas fini sur le
livre les sept jeunes de lumière dans le
coeur de dernier vous explique tout ça
très bien
le deuxième le deuxième la deuxième
erreur à laquelle je je le pensais je
les plus ça vous reviendra
voilà ça prend on va revenir sur sur des
exemples précis on est par exemple sur
l'exemple que qu'on se pose enfin la
question qu'on se pose tous si je suis
propriétaire d'un logement
comment locataires crée des nuisances
etc ont fait fait par des nuisances
commises par mon locataire est ce que
moi propriétaire je suis responsable et
à un support juridique puisque chaque
copropriétaire doit utiliser son lot
conformément au règlement et le
propriétaire doit transmettre ce
règlement aux locataires et s'assurer
qu'ils le respectent donc oui c'est le
propriétaire qui est le seul responsable
mais même s'il ya des actions directes
possible entre autres le locateur leurs
locataires mais ses propriétaires qui
est responsable
il doit soit trouvée une solution soit
mettre en oeuvre la rupture du contrat
dubai s'il ne le fait pas il peut il
peut être être poursuivi et donc c'est
une situation
j'en ai une journée une avant-hier ou le
bailleur met en oeuvre parce qu'il ya
des plaintes des voisins et c'est assez
traumatisant alors juste un règlement il
peut y avoir aussi des choses plus
précises dans le règlement
conventionnelle de copropriété on peut
aller au delà notamment vous avez des
règlements qui interdisent certains
types de commerces qui interdisent
certains types d'activités professeur de
piano
elles sont pas toutes licite mais le
règlement de copropriété ajoute et peut
ajouter dans certains cas on peut être
amené à modifier le règlement de
copropriété c'est pas facile mais c'est
possible pour justement éviter ces
troubles de voisinage
jean philippe mariani est avec nous ce
soir pour répondre à toutes vos
questions concernant les conflits de
voisinage est avocat spécialisé en droit
de l'immobilier
on a déjà commencé cette émission avec
un certain nombre de questions on
continue vous êtes présents sur le chat
du figaro et puis sur youtube et
justement il ya gros matou qui vient
d'arriver sur le chat bonsoir gros matou
vous nous dites je me fait harceler et
épié par un couple de personnes depuis
on m'a conseillé de déménager mais ce
n'est pas facile étant donné que je n'ai
pas les moyens et que je suis en
formation qu'est ce qu'on peut répondre
à gros matou s'il a déjà là sur un
conflit 2016 50 conflit conflit est bien
installé c'est c'est compliqué un des
conseils c'est pour ça c'est d'agir très
tôt parce que plus on va s'installer
dans le conflit plus on va créer des
cicatrices et plus avec difficile de
passer là je vois que la demande de
conciliation de justice si les
informations qu'il n'a pas de moyens la
distinction est pas très simple entre
conciliateur et médiateurs mais disons
que le conciliateur est intégré c'est un
personnage officiel qui est intégrée à
la juridiction et il est gratuit
il est un peu débordé en ce moment parce
que sont sa saisine est devenu enfin en
tout cas la mise en oeuvre d'un mode
amiable est devenu obligatoire notamment
dans les litiges inférieurs à 5000 euros
mais c'est vrai que le conciliateur peut
être la solution il utilise globalement
les mêmes techniques que le médiateur
même m6
débat voile alors que les médiateurs
sont indépendants et la médiation
la plupart du temps et payantes pour
continuer à aider gros matou il ajoute
une information qui qui est un peu
inquiétante puisque il nous dit j'ai
même eu une période d'agoraphobie car
une des deux personnes a tenté de mettre
ses menaces à exécution en tentant de
rentrer chez moi par la fenêtre j'habite
au rez-de-chaussée et j'ai peur de les
croiser la paix oui là ont servi sur une
violation de domicile
on est sur du harcèlement elle a
évidemment il ya quand même des réponses
pénales parfois qui sont possibles date
du conflit de voisinage là oui on est
dans l'atteinte à la personne mais
néanmoins l'intervention d'un tiers
c'est ce qu'on disait le tiers qui se
manifeste et qui dit un problème est ce
qu'on continue comme ça où est ce que
finalement on recherche une solution à
ce que vous voulez en parler puisque en
médiation ce qui peut être intéressant
dans les conflits bien installé ses
convois séparément les deux parties on
écoute leurs récits et on voit comment
on peut les comprendre
c'est un oeil extérieur qui déjà va
pouvoir démêler la pelote
avec un regain de trembler car il faut
comprendre les cartes des histoires les
témoignages sont toujours divergent mais
on arrive à comprendre d'où vient le
tout vient le problème
alors revenons aux conflits de voisinage
peut-être plus proche de nous qu'ils ne
dégénèrent pas sur des situations
inquiétantes voire grave
les beaux jours sont arrivés même si ça
ne se voit pas encore tout à fait en
ile-de-france mais en tout cas les beaux
jours sont arrivées la saison des
barbecues va commencer on l'espère on a
en fait gêné par la fumée du barbecue
que son voisin c'est qu'une situation
donc vous avez certainement souvent et
qu est-ce qu on peut aussi considérer
que la fumée d'un barbecue c'est une
nuisance est est ce que ça peut être
sanctionné c'est une nuisance mais qui
parce que dans là il s'agit pas
seulement de nuisance il faut qu'elle
soit anormal il ya une appréciation vous
faites une fête
voilà pour justement célébrer le
déconfinement vous allez faire la fête
jusqu'à 2 heures du matin c'est une
nuisance
si ça vous arrive une fois dans l'année
la jurisprudence considérera que ça
n'est pas anormal si comme j'ai eu le
cas pour des amis d'ailleurs vous avez
au dessus de chez vous un entrepreneur
de fait on s'était pas c'était pas
polémique c'était bien avant le
confinement mais qui tous les vendredis
tous les samedis installe une sono
professionnel au dessus de chez vous ai
fait une boîte de nuit jusqu'à 4 heures
du matin vous êtes dans le nord la
normale
donc le barbecue vous pouvez aussi
trouver un stakhanoviste du baryton
j'adore ça mais enfin de là ça veut dire
qu'il voulait en fait quatre fois par
semaine tous les soirs la cbi lors de la
normale vous retrouvez la situation du
restaurant pourront parler du bruit qui
est la première cause peut-être je pense
d'eux
de pousser zine de conflit les odeurs de
restaurants ce sont quand même viennent
à mon sens en deuxième position mais je
vais vous poser la question est ce qu
est ce que le recours qu'on peut avoir
vis-à-vis de son voisin est le même que
pour un restaurant si j'ai des odeurs
trop prégnant de mon voisin est ce que
ce sont les mêmes recours que je peux
avoir sur un restaurant qui est en
permanence en bas de chez moi exactement
c'est la même nuisances olfactives
simplement le restaurant vous l'imposent
cinq six sept jours sur sept et le
voisin il va falloir voir à quelle
fréquence
il vous fait supporter ça et c'est sûr
que sauf encore une fois comportement
vraiment vraiment répétitif
ça sera plus compliqué à l'égard du
voisin en revanche là aussi comme pour
le bruit sur les restaurants aujourd'hui
c'est cadré
il ya des sceaux veut dire qu'il ya des
systèmes de filtration qui sont imposés
on peut pas rejeter des odeurs d'abord
il ya des normes très précises sur
l'extraction il faut aujourd'hui dans
des restaurants des conduits qui sortent
en terrasse en routeur sur les toits ou
voilà il ya des mia même des sections on
va jusqu'à 1 français menait les
règlements on a des sections en fonction
du type de cuisine si vous avez de la
restauration rapide ça n'est pas la même
norme que si vous avez une véritable
cuisine et en dernier recours parce que
bon il ya des normes mais même si la
norme est respecté et que la nuisance
est constatée bah vous êtes qui sont
basses annoncées pour remédier au passé
intéressant lorsque matt ward war
victoire résoudre c'est une
responsabilité sans faute
c'est une responsabilité objective si il
y a trouble anormal
on doit trouver une solution même si
vous respectez les normes phoniques mais
que le bruit dérange vous devez trouver
une solution et aujourd'hui on a des
destructeurs d'odeurs qui sont chères
pour le pour le restaurateur mais qui
normalement assure la vente la fête est
alors dans le cas de nuisances
olfactives générées par des usines cette
fois ci le problème semble peut-être
autrement plus complexe qu'en est il
alors là on va sur le droit public
la plupart du temps puisque ce sont des
normes d'environnement que je vous
avouerai - moins maîtrisé mais d'un
autre côté quand on arrive à ce type de
nuisance
jusque-là collective en général il est
pas très difficile d'avoir le concours
des collectivités et des autorités
administratives qui peuvent aussi
intervenir là on va être vraiment sur le
respect de normes d'environnement
quand même aujourd'hui ont le vent en
poupe avec toujours la limite de
l'intérêt économique et sanitaire aussi
il ya aussi un enjeu sanitaire parce que
qui dit les odeurs émises par des usines
au voyage dans l'attitude qui prime sur
l'odeur de viande grillée on est
potentiellement sur des sur des
émanations toxiques
là encore place est vraiment plus
directe la cie césar sur twitter qui
nous demande que faire si on est
importuné par les odeurs de poubelles de
nos voisins ou celle de leurs animaux
alors belle donc là ce serait pas une
configuration de copropriété mais on va
avoir a priori le côté répétitif parce
que effectivement on peut faire
intervenir
il régnera une dimension sanitaire parce
que qui dit odeur de poubelles l'adie
potentiellement prolifération germes
bactéries donc
je pense qu'on a on a des moyens
d'action hormis la discussion
effectivement toujours avec avec le
voisin tenons sait quelque chose
alors il peut y avoir déjà nos effectifs
due à la présence d'animaux plutôt à
proximité d'animaux en nombre ou alors
de grande taille on va dire non mais si
si ça c'est un cas plus rares mais mais
qui est quand même très peur que l'on
rencontre c'est j'allais dire la mamie
au 17 chats dans un ouais donc là vous
allez avoir contrôle sanitaire parce que
c'est pareil ce sont des odeurs qui en
fait masquer un problème plus profond
viennent voilà d'hygiène et donc là il
ya dangereuse et ça veut dire que le
voisin qui est incommodé où les voisins
qui sont accommodés c'est pas juste
aller taper à la porte des individus
qu'il faut faire c'est tout de suite
recourir à des interlocuteurs
je pense qu'on valait ce que quelqu'un
là vous allez rentrer dans un quelqu'un
qui à 18 15 chats chiens je dis on va
voir par exemple dans le cas d'animaux
en nombre en surnombre dans
l'appartement d'un voisin l'a le service
sanitaire de la mairie d'accord parce
que là ça me semble direct vous allez
pas réussir à résoudre le conflit
puisque c'est un conflit de valeurs pour
l'autre on imagine bien que c'est toute
sa vie et vous allez avoir de grandes
difficultés à communiquer donc là il
faut mettre en avant le côté sanitaire
revenons au bruit jean philippe mariani
qui est la première cause de conflits de
voisinage je parlais tout à l'heure des
beaux jours qui arrivent des barbecues
et des odeurs maintenant avec l'arrivée
des beaux jours dont on entretient son
jardin et puis qui dit jardin jeudi
pelouse et donc tondeuse
on coupe aussi les arbustes les arbres
et donc tout ça fait bien bien bien bien
de bruit pour certains qu'est ce qui est
autorisé qu'est ce qui ne l'est pas est
ce qu'on fonctionne en fonction de ce
que dit la mairie de ce que dit la loi
des horaires des jours telle loi la loi
sa pelouse quand on fait la loi ne dit
rien en revanche iliad héritage il ya
des usages locaux clairement pour
l'utilisation de la tondeuse
moi je sais que dans la ville où j'ai
l'occasion de tondo doit pas tondre le
dimanche matin on peut trouver des
réglementations sur le site de sa mairie
on regarde les horaires qui sont
autorisés pour tondre sa pelouse toutes
les mairies n'ont pas mais généralement
les mairies qui ont un habitat avec
jardin ont réglementé cette cette
question de la tondeuse comme l ont
réglementé aussi les horreurs de travaux
parce que c'est pareil à la tondeuse
même si la perceuse à 8 heures du matin
le dimanche qui est peu agréable donc il
ya cette réglementation à laquelle on
peut faire référence
encore une fois dans un premier temps
sur un mode amiable au rebond et alors
si ça n'est pas respectée si mon voisin
ton la pelouse même le coup d'une fois
je suis avec des amis en terrasse mon
voisin décide de tondre la pelouse à 15
heures l'après midi est en train de
faire ma sieste siroter ma grenadine
j'en sais rien c'est quoi mon recours je
peux il peut être sanctionné à hauteur
de combien ces grandes dames a fait un
fait unique
à mon avis ça marchera pas ça marchera
pas on essaiera toujours de trouver
d'expliquer et de dire c'est vivre
ensemble c'est aussi supporter oui
forcément ce type de désagrément c'est
la répétition c'est la répéter ce que
risque un voisin qui fait fonctionner sa
tondeuse de façon récurrente je suis
allé voir plusieurs fois ils n'arrêtent
pas donc au bout d'un moment c'est que
les changes à l'amiable ne fonctionne
pas c'est la justice qui interviendra là
la justice intervient alors sur le plan
du non respect de la réglementation et
de la menthe pénal comme je fais plus de
pénal depuis longtemps je m'avancerai
pas mais il ya peut-être une possibilité
de contraventions l existant tapage
nocturne ça y'a pas difficulté après sur
le nombre d'infractions une fois qu'on a
tenté de résoudre le problème et ses bas
ce sont des dommages intérêts ce sont
des dommages et intérêts que le juge
peut accorder à la partie qui a supporté
cette ce trouble anormal
il peut aussi enjoindre le respect sous
astreinte
là c'est une pénalité préventive
astreinte de temps d'euros par attendent
euros par infraction constatée
à ce moment là ont fait constater à
chaque fois par l'huissier qu'il ya eu
infraction et ensuite on va faire
liquider l'astreinte
c'est lourd mais ça peut quand même
apparaître dissuasives et toujours à
propos de jardin jean philippe mariani
est ce qu'on a le droit de brûler nos
déchets verts dans le jardin de tout ce
qu'on a pu enlever arracher que ce soit
des branches des feuilles et ça crée un
seul avec les cowboys mais on va dire
dans l'enceinte de notre résidence en a
le droit de faire l'écobuage est
clairement réglementé voir mais j'ai mon
expérience corse puisque j'ai été
pompier volontaire en corse où les
écobuages était sont interdits pendant
une grande partie de l'année et je pense
que là partout une réglementation
précise elle est locale parce qu'elle
dépend évidemment de la situation
météorologique et de l'hérault maîtrise
mais là je suis à peu près certain que
les cowboys âge puisque c'était le nom
technique les pompiers utilisent
écobuage non signalée at elle un brin on
fonçait pour faire éteindre
immédiatement le feu là il ya des
risques de très grave parce que si ça se
communique dans certains vous pouvez sur
un éco village brûlé une forêt de et
parfois des habite mettre en danger des
habitations
donc là il ya une réglementation et là
il y aura sanction là clairement il y
aura contravention potentiel c'est une
réglementation de protection de sécurité
civile que je connais pas dans le détail
mais dont je suis certain de
l'application est alors toujours un
rapport avec les propriétaires de
jardins si mon voisin n'entretient pas
son jardin qui le laisse en friche qu'il
ya cumul des gravats divers et variés et
autres rebuts est ce que ça peut être
considéré comme de la nuisance
si je considère que ça me gêne alors sur
l'aspect esthétique je serai mesuré en
revanche les plantations qui déborde de
la propriété là il ya une
une réglementation peut pas toujours
coupée par soi même mais on peut la
obtenir des astreintes
j'ai eu le cas d'un conflit tellement
cristallisé cocon en est venu à la
saisie immobilière
il y avait eu quatre ou cinq astreintes
ne voulait pas tailler ces chaînes il
était allée en cassation
il ya une fixation et au bout de trois
ou quatre astreintes on arrivait à
trente ou quarante cinquante mille euros
et en était en saisies immobilières de
la maison du voisin
ça veut dire quoi concrètement ça veut
dire qu'ils allaient perdre sa maison il
n'avait plus aurait dû mettre les pieds
il est long l'allèle à vendre d'accord
on à l'opposé de la bande
oui parce que comme ils ne paient pas
les astreintes il devenait débiteurs du
voisin et pour se faire payer le voisin
n'arrivait pas à exécuter justifiait qui
avait pas de compte bancaire il
n'arrivait pas à trouver et donc ils en
arrivaient à vendre la maison du voisin
pour récupérer ses cinquante mille euros
bien évidemment la différence entre le
prix de vente allaient être restitués
aux militaires mais il allait devoir
partir et c'est arrivé si on est allé
jusque là ouais donc ces extrêmes et il
faut vraiment quelqu'un de très têtu en
face pour en arriver là mais quand vous
vous enfermez dans le conflit oui faut
connaître de ces situations
alors certains pourraient mettre en
avant l'idée d'une entrave à la liberté
de chacun
je donne l'exemple qu'on a cité un peu
tout à l'heure par rapport aux bruits
mon voisin fais de la musique
régulièrement il fait la fête chez lui
c'est qu'on les conversations avec ses
amis m'empêche de dormir
est ce que j'ai le droit de l'en
empêcher où ça va être à kehl à quel
moment ça peut être considéré comme une
entrave à la liberté c'est le conflit de
base qui est arbitré dans le texte de
référence de la théorie yaka permis ils
ces jugements un texte qui dit qu'on use
librement de son bien et ces notions de
bon sens que les juges ont mis en oeuvre
cette liberté elle s'arrête là là ou là
où commence celle des autres
et là où commence la souffrance voulons
donc encore une fois ça n'est pas à il
m'agace à écouter sa musique
il est 22 heures bon bah oui ils
m'agacent à écouter sa musique et je
vais il est deux heures du matin et
c'est du hard rock un peu d'autres types
de musique
là on va être parce que là ça me
réveille ça m'empêche de dormir
et là on va être celle des conséquences
sur mon sur ma santé sur ma santé
mais évidemment sur ce anormal durer
toujours débat matière d'appréciation
on pourra pas on peut mesurer les
décibels mais on peut pas toujours
mesurer l'impact psychologique real il
ya aussi parfois cette déception c'est
que c'est le danger les gens font des
focalisation sur des bruines et
l'acousticien vous dis oui mais bon par
rapport au bruit de la rue ça c'est pas
des liens en débat voilà mais si l'autre
a fait une fixation il va quand même
souffrir et ça sera pas forcément
considérés comme sains comme un trouble
anormal
alors jean philippe marini vous nous
parler des bruits de la rue qu'en est il
des nuisances en ville provoqués par les
bars les terrasses de restaurants qui
sont qui sont ouvertes et dans la
clientèle peut s'attabler jusqu'à
parfois très tard
le voisinage il est obligé de subir non
non non aujourd'hui ils sont soumis aux
mêmes règles
j'ai déjeuné récemment dans un
restaurant où j'étais pas allé depuis
depuis quatre cinq ans mais peut-être
plus si je me souvienne une très belle
très belle terrasse ouverte sur la
défense voilà j'arrive convives et je
voyais terrasses fermées donc un très
bel vérandas cathédrale
quel dommage et le serveur même
m'expliquer 1 0 mais les précédents
propriétaires ont fini par baisser les
bras ils se sont fait condamner une fois
deux fois trois fois
c'était des plaintes du voici 7 et les
plaintes du voisinage il y avait tout un
tas de pavillons on était dans un
quartier très résidentiel et ben ils ont
fini par lâcher et les nouveaux
propriétaires se sont organisés pour ne
pas avoir à supporter est à craindre ce
type d'action ils ont fermé la terrasse
donc vous avez aussi un autre restaurant
que je vais où ils vous servant terrasse
a plus qu'à 22h30 à 22h36 voter vous
partez vous rentrez dans aujourd'hui
c'est quand même difficile pour pour une
exploitation commerciale de s'affranchir
de ces règles dès lors que les voisins
sont son sont mobilisés et sont prêts à
engager les procédures
on avait un peu plus tôt dans l'après
midi quand on a teasé et fait la
promotion de ce rendez vous de ce soir
sur les conflits de voisinage eu des
retours et des commentaires et des
témoignages et et on a celui ci par
exemple en rapport avec les nuisances
nocturnes générés par par les terrasses
justement et qui est tout à fait raccord
avec l'actualité et en particulier la
ville de paris et son maire madame la
maire anne hidalgo
cody nuxe new deal et terrasse éphémère
permanente autorisé par madame la maire
de paris anne hidalgo produisent des
nuisances sonores énorme
est ce légal de faire ça sans la
concertation des parisiens autour c'est
vrai que faut rappeler que depuis cette
crise sanitaire les restaurants qui ont
plu rouvriront à droite et des terrasses
sur la chaussée pour pouvoir accueillir
leurs clients c'est reste pour l'instant
elles sont à l'extérieur et peuvent
générer du coût des mises en scène pour
certains c'est vrai qu'il est là les
parisiens n'ont pas été consultés qu'est
ce qu'en est-il d'un point de vue
législatif est ce qu'ils ont des droits
pour faire interdire ces terrasses alors
celle inverse puisque en fait
normalement on ne doit pas occuper le
domaine public
là on parle de terrasses qui sont saufs
concessions ces concessions étaient très
réglementée et elle imposait évidemment
aux bénéficiaires de la concession de
respecter le voisinage mais avec la
fermeture des restaurants et la
situation économique qui en a résulté
c'est sûr qu'on a ouvert
on a ouvert on a fait un appel d'air
pour leur permettre de survivre
maintenant il donc là on vient de sortir
d'un temps où il n'y avait que la
possibilité de servir en terrasse
combien de temps on va un peu compenser
les huit mois de fermeture
là on est dans une situation moi je
pense que le droit va avoir beaucoup de
mal à passer à passer et peut demander
aux parents d'être patient c'est ça non
mais ceux qui sont gênés en concertation
j'entendais sans concertation avec les
parisiens
c'est tout et nord c'est là c'est là où
je pense que le modèle viable et est
bien meilleure par ce projet vous
demande pardon je suis je souhaitais
vous sur votre place parce que sinon les
internautes évoluent et j'avais laisse
par ma timidité naturelle était revenu
donc ça va être divisé le droit va
passer c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné
on va considérer que les circonstances
exceptionnelles qui avait justifié cette
autorisation oui bah on va y mettre fin
et ses terrasses vont disparaître quand
comment on est dans un équilibre
bon c'est pas tout à fait le débat mais
par exemple on a le problème entre les
bailleurs et justement les restaurants
qui doivent payer leur loyer alors
qu'ils peuvent pas exploiter leur fonds
de commerce
le droit est en train de donner pour
savoir qui paye qui payent pas les
juridictions se déchire un jour la cour
de cassation va trancher jusqu'à quand
et la vraie question c'est il faut que
les deux arrivent à survivre
donc il faut discuter et là c'est pareil
ce que si on dit au parisien la moitié
de vos restaurants vont faire faillite
je pense qu'ils sont pas contents
absolument mal à faire le clown terriens
qu'on salue ce soir sur youtube il est
en direct sur le chat du figaro sur le
compte youtube du figaro
respectons tout simplement la
tranquillité de nos voisins dit-il
affirmation plein de bon sens et voilà
si on avait toujours se mettre à la
place de l'otan on est là et on est dans
le plaisir de la fête etc
et après il faut regarder puis savoir
s'arrêter
c'est aussi voilà c'est aussi la clé de
se dire je fais la fête tu fais du bruit
mais je m'arrête à 2 heures du matin et
je pousse pas le bouchon trop loin
là c'est facile on est on est au paradis
quand on aime ça c'est bien c'est bien
parce qu'on n'en est pas capable que les
problèmes harry existe on continue les
questions concrètes mon voisin du dessus
à un enfant en bas âge qui court qui
crie ma voisine du dessus marche
régulièrement en talons l'immeuble et
mal isolés ces bruits on l'imaginait
peuvent être perçus comme des huit ans
alors que font partie d'une vie
absolument standard est ce qu'on peut
empêcher les gens de vivre non éduqué ce
qu'on peut forcer un propriétaire à
insonoriser son logement par exactement
évidemment ce canton à soi même un
enfant et que le voisin bien vous dire
mais tenez le un peu tranquille
eric on sait combien c'est difficile de
tenir un enfant tranquille on peut être
un peu feu la solution là et les
techniques et effectivement on va passer
par la procédure de constats des niveaux
sonores des chocs du côté problème avec
les enfants c'est que ça peut être très
irrégulier très abrupte tiff une fois
qu'on aura constaté qu'on est bien à un
niveau inacceptable
il va falloir mettre en oeuvre les
mesures d'isolation phonique
elles existent les solutions techniques
existent prem's et qu'elles ont un coût
lorsqu'on peut imposer un propriétaire
de dépenser de l'argent pour satisfaire
les requêtes de son voisin tout à fait
dès lors que dès lors qu'on a constaté
le trouble de voisinage
il ya une bien volé indemnisation du
préjudice subi mais il ya surtout un
volet mise en oeuvre il faut que ça
cesse donc soit vous arrivez à museler
votre enfance pas forcément la meilleure
solution
soit vous mettez en oeuvre un plancher
insonorisé on a on a ces débats souvent
lorsque la mode de la moquette étant
largement les gens installent des
parquets ça revient et oui oui et
installe des parcs est content mais même
avec ce type d'installation on peut
aujourd'hui arriver à des résultats
d'isolation phonique donc c'est une
question de moyens et de coût mais en
tout cas on doit trouver la solution
parce que le voisin ne doit pas souffrir
ou être obligée de partir alors oui ça
c'est le aux gros problème j'ai eu des
cas où des ja ont revendu leurs maisons
à cause par dépit oui mais faute de
pouvoir parvenir à régler le problème
si on a besoin de preuves pour renforcer
notre requête est ce qu'on peut
solliciter ses voisins
et demander des témoignages qui vont
être de fait
une sorte de renforts on le sait appuyer
notre requête auprès de la justice ou du
médiateur absolument voilà la preuve se
fait par tous moyens donc par voie
d'attestation les voisins il faut
connaître les liens ce qui peut aussi y
avoir des coteries peut y avoir des des
réseaux au sein des copropriétés donc
ils doivent préciser leur lien de
parenté d'alliance etc et au delà des
attestations qui sont quand même des
preuves importantes parce que c'est
surtout on va voir l'étendue des
personnes touchées s'il ya une seule
personne touchée on peut s'interroger
sur le côté psychologique de lui de sa
perception
lorsqu'on va avoir plusieurs personnes
on est déjà dans un champ plus plus plus
propice il peut y avoir aussi le constat
d'huissier et après la preuve
scientifique par l'enregistrement
mais oui bien sûr alors les témoignages
sont parfois jean-michel mariani c'est
j'ai fait une erreur sur votre nom
jean-philippe excusez moi jean philippe
paradis c'est parce qu'il ya un
internaute qui s'appelle michel parfois
les problèmes se ressemblent insolvables
et justement ma voisine me pictoon et
colis alors après avoir prévenu le
syndic toujours rien que faire mais la
ccl vol c'est du vol de correspondance
avec la plainte
ça c'est plus du trouble de voisinage
cessé de la pathologie donc après si
elle est propriétaire
oui non là je pense qu'on n'est même pas
dans le trouble de voisinage quelqu'un
qui vous vole votre courrier c'est
quelqu'un qui commet un délit
après il faut mettre en place un système
de preuves il faut il faut tracer des
faut faire l'effort de pouvoir rapporter
la preuve qui est pas facile et peut se
faire aider par un professionnel qui va
constater les opérations mais
normalement là le droit pénal doit
passer et là on parle des forces de
l'ordre ont recours à la police on
dépose une plainte mais est ce que ce
sont les seules autorités compétentes
pour faire cesser les nuisances ou y en
a d'autres que les forces de l'ordre
dans ces cas là où la situation dégénère
on n'est plus dans le conflit de
voisinage sur un bruit et l'odeur on est
vraiment là dans les forces de l'ordre
elles vont intervenir par par tradition
parce que tout conflit de voisinage peut
dégénérer en violences hélas elles sont
dans leur rôle de prévenir la violence
ça c'est quand même la grande force de
notre système juridique mais après elles
peuvent se retrouver confronté à un
conflit civil
l'histoire de la place de parking où ça
déborde si elles sont si on en vient aux
mains ils vont intervenir si si ça hurle
si bon mais derrière c'est un prime s'il
est souvent les gens combien de temps je
vais déposer plainte
il faut une infraction là vous parliez
d'un vol de colis donc de correspondance
infraction ils ont voulu rentrer par ma
fenêtre infraction quand on est sur du
pur troubles de voisinage
sauf réglementation précise assorti de
contraventions etc
on n'est pas dans l'infraction pénale on
est dans la procédure civile qui est
plus lourde parce que dans ce cas là ça
va être à la victime de mettre en oeuvre
je pensais même mais même par rapport
aux colis il peut mettre en oeuvre avec
un huissier un petit stratagème pour
arriver à montrer à tracer ces colis qu
effectivement parfois demander des
caméras de surveillance lorsque c'est
possible c'est très réglementé pour
arriver à établir ce pour avoir son
élément de preuve
jean philippe mariani et spécialistes et
experts en droit immobilier réponse ce
soir en direct sur figaro l'arrivée sur
youtube à toutes vos questions en
rapport avec les conflits de voisinage
donc vous n'hésitez pas à nous faire
part de vos commentaires et de vos
questions et de vos témoignages en
rapport avec le sujet en préparant cette
émission jean philippe mariani
j'ai découvert qu'on peut utiliser la
protection juridique de notre assurance
oui pour
les conflits de voisinage et cm1 c'est
de plus en plus moi je suis de plus en
plus sollicités par des gens qui
justement ont recours à ce contrat qui
se généralise et qui maintenant
fonctionne assez bien
comme toutes les assurances vous
garantissez contre un risque de procès
peut y avoir des périmètres variables
certaines protections juridiques
est ce que le divorce considérant que
c'était trop fréquent en région
parisienne d'autres exclus le dry
travail bon mais globalement je les
litiges de voisinage sont sont pris en
charge
il vous assure déjà une intervention
préalable et ça peut être efficace ce
fameux tiers qui vient solliciter
s'ils le font bien s'ils sont bien
formés ils peuvent avoir ce petit effet
médiation et sinon ensuite ils prennent
en charge une partie des honoraires de
l'avocat
sam est prise en charge financière voit
la prise en charge financière ça n'est
plus comme avant l'avocat d'assurance
qui va être payé un tarif très réduit
donc faire une prestation un peu de
masse stéréotypé non maintenant on peut
choisir son avocat mme et ça va couvrir
la moitié en général des frais réels
donc ce qui veut dire qu'avec
l'indemnisation qu'on peut obtenir en
cas de succès de la procédure
on arrive à ce que le poids de 2 des
honoraires et de la procédure sont
allégées supporters et surtout on peut
le mettre en oeuvre
parce qu'on a tout de suite une mise de
fonds pour démarrer le dossier avec une
provision jambes dit mariani j'aimerais
qu'on reparle et qu'on redéfinisse et
qu'on guident nos internautes sur
des intermédiaires ou en tout cas des
aides auxquelles on peut recourir qui
sont en l'occurrence le médiateur ou le
conciliateur de justice qu'on a évoqué
tout à l'heure qu'est ce que c'est et
comment on trouve ce médiateur ou sous
conciliateur de justice qui peut nous
aider à résoudre un conflit de voisinage
à l'amiable
voilà le conciliateur il est rattaché au
tribunal judiciaire
donc c'est une institution il fait
partie de l'institution on peut le il ya
la requête de saisine du conciliateur et
sur le site service public.fr avec le
processus donc voilà ça c'est cadré
la difficulté c'est qu'ils sont encore
trop peu nombreux et que la récente
modification législative qui imposent le
recours à un mode amiable comme les gens
n'ont pas toujours les moyens de me
payer un mode amiable se rabat sur le
conciliateur qui en ce moment est
débordé voilà donc ça c'est le premier
la première étape et je rappelle qu'elle
est obligatoire alors en théorie elle
est obligatoire pour les troubles de
voisinage justement
sauf qu'il ya eu un petit pataquès au
niveau législatif et que cette
prescription général s'est traduit pour
l'instant par des points très techniques
de bornage de choses comme ça donc
mais a priori très vite on verra que le
législateur va imposer je pense le
recours à un mode amiable on confie le
voisinage je fais une parenthèse
pourquoi c'est c'est très judicieux
parce que le conflit de voisinage fait
partie de ces types de litiges ou même
si vous saisissez la justice et si vous
obtenez satisfaction la difficulté c'est
que vous allez maintenir la relation
avec l'autre parent absolument t on
retrouve le même chose avec le droit de
la famille sa part aux blessés voilà
vous échapper avec votre votre ex
machina mais après il reste les enfants
à élever et on a encore dix quinze ans
soit à devoir gérer des chevaux et le
vrai cerveau avoir gain de cause ça
résoudra pas à la règle et on a gagné
les relances et gagné une bataille mais
potentiellement la guerre peut continuer
absolument ces cas là lorsqu'il ya un
enjeu de maintien de la relation au delà
de la décision judiciaire
n'importe quelle décision judiciaire
risquent en fait d'alimenter le conflit
même si on a raison et même si le juge
vous donnerai donc c'est pour ça qu'ils
ont va imposer le modèle viable alors
les autres noms d'amis absolue médiateur
donc là vous avez j'ai parlé des
permanences j'ai parlé de la fédération
française
médiation je pense qu'on peut les
trouver et ensuite et là j'y tiens
beaucoup
vous avez les avocats qui se sont
investis comme vous voilà dans la
médiation mais on est de plus en plus
nombreux
sebha dans la médiation vous avez les
avocats du processus collaboratif je
leur fais un signe amical
parce que c'est bon c'est un peu la
rolls le processus collaboratif ça vient
des états unis
sup magnifique technique un peu cher
mais dans certains cas ça peut ça peut
ça vaut le coup largement en tout cas
les avocats qui sont formés au processus
collaboratif vous avez un annuaire des
praticiens français du droit
collaboratif
ils sont à même nous traitez votre
dossier avec cette sensibilité moi
aujourd'hui
et puis vous avez les avocats qui
communiquent là dessus qu'ils sont
simplement formés à la négociation
raisonnée ou au même un peu à la
procédure participative
tous les avocats qui communique sur sur
cette compétence
je pense sont intéressants parce que ils
vont pas tout de suite vous proposer la
solution judiciaire il vous dira voilà
on va peut-être essayer autre chose et
moi j'ai complètement changer mon mode
de fonctionnement avance est recommandé
de pages en vertu de l article vous
risquez sagesse a terminé à un problème
est ce qu'on peut en parler eva débuts
en le pratiquant que ça oui
samaras à ma voix lasse et mes services
ou des complices à rézé mans les
procédures ans est le plus radin moment
parce qu'on a qu'on est quand même
confronté à une lenteur de la justice là
qui devient qui devient terrifiante
moi j'ai un client qui vient me voir il
est poursuivi tient en résiliation de
bail parce qu'on lui à l'office hlm le
poursuit en résiliation de bail parce
qu'il terrorisait conteste mais ils
auraient terrorisé sa voisine
eh bien il est fixé en septembre 2022
oui en effet donc la voisine à tort ou à
raison elle va devoir encore le support
clé pendant c'est difficile on est plus
dans la réponse adaptée et c'est vrai
que si on arrive à mettre en oeuvre
mais on a quand même fait on a quand
même fait un grand pas dans l'efficacité
je continue à vous livrer quelques
témoignages d'internautes qui nous ont
dit ce qu'ils vivent en matière de
conflits de voisinage et bode qui nous a
livré son témoignage sur twitter nous
dit quand j'habitais chez mes parents on
avait une voisine qui jeter ses détritus
casser des oeufs
devant notre porte cassée notre série ou
encore jeté des kilos de viande par la
fenêtre 7 jours sur 7
ma mère a fini par vendre l'appartement
on appelait le syndic la police mais en
vain c'est vrai que parfois on se sent
complètement démuni face à des
situations qui qui dégénèrent parfois en
drame
là ce qui me vient à l'esprit c'est
quand même con on a affaire à une
personne a priori déséquilibré dit que
c'est là où on changement bien sûr on se
dit ça normal c'est vrai il faut il faut
trouver des solutions etc
mais dans dans la dans la gestion de
conflits on se demande pourquoi
qu'est ce qui peut pousser quelqu'un à
se comporter ainsi
parfois il ya il ya un intérêt parfois
il ya un mépris de l'autre parfois c'est
une volonté simplement d'exister
il ya des gens qui martyrisent les
autres parce que bon il faut arriver à
identifier et lalla comme ça en
entendant ça je me dis c'est quelqu'un
qui aurait besoin d'une mesure de
protection
on est en présence de quelqu'un qui a
qu'il ya un problème psychologique est
donc là la solution c'est de rechercher
sa famille de comprendre pourquoi
évidemment elle est seule pourquoi elle
n'est pas pris en charge au niveau de
ses troubles psychologiques et aussi
parfois de faire intervenir certains
services d'aidé à la personne de
protection des majeurs
parce que c'est peut-être tout
simplement quelqu'un qui a acquis en
situation de détresse un oui et de
fragilité il nécessite l'intervention
frappe jamais dit et qui dépasse le la
demande de curateurs elle peut être
présentée par toute personne ayant un
intérêt les assolements la famille pas
seulement la famille
et il peut y avoir des sur les histoires
de personnes qui ont plusieurs chars etc
on a aussi cette dimension de solitude
donc évidemment quand je l'entends
parfois quand je dis aux clients ben on
va chercher j'ai cherché à comprendre
mais vous êtes du côté de l'autre et en
compassion non c'est pas c'est pas
seulement cette démarche là c'est une
démarche d'efficacité
si on arrive à comprendre comment
fonctionne que l'autre on va peut-être
trouvé la solution et finalement si on
peut faire intervenir un curateur qui va
mettre en place un suivi une aide et c
est qu on règle le problème
bien oui on a fait du bien à l'autre
mais c'est pas ce qu'on recherche ce
qu'on recherche c'est une solution alors
si mon voisin ne veut pas appliquer la
décision de justice est ce que je peux
le faire à sa place par exemple taille
est l'arbre qui empiète sur ma propriété
des moulures à la clôture qui n'a pas
existé sur mon terrain ce sera t il ya
des cas où mais la plupart du temps ça
va être le régime de l'astreinte que je
vous décrivais pour la coupe des arbres
non vous pouvez pas vous faire justice à
vous même est passé sur la propriété du
voisin pour réparer etc
mais normalement par le jeu de
l'astreinte comme elles peuvent être par
jour
de retard dans l'exécution d'une tâche
vous allez finir par avoir un argument
financier qui est important et dans ce
type de conflit
vous avez un interlocuteur qui est
solvable priori puisqu'il est
propriétaire immobilier
donc c'est quand même et ça peut se
terminer à l'extrême comme je le disais
en saisies immobilières en général les
gens réagissent à avant donc oui les
décisions de justice on peut les faire
respecter en france yahia que les
situations de personnes totalement
insolvables qui l'a sont difficiles à
régler mais heureusement en immobilier
bon bah c'est souvent entre
propriétaires et copropriétaires
donc là on a des solutions alors parfois
jean philippe mariani
le propriétaire est gêné par par des
nuisances d'un voisin mais qui le voisin
en l'occurrence n'offre absolument pas
la loi mais ça nous arrange malgré tout
complètement dingos dans le quotidien
comment est ce qu'on peut faire cesser
ces nuisances qu'ils ne sont pas nous
qui sont considérés par nous comme des
nuisances mais que la sur lesquels la
loi ne peut pas intervenir
quels sont les leviers qu'on peut
actionner pour essayer d'arriver à nos
fins en ayant un du poids si vous voulez
dans notre dans notre requête
le levier c'est le projet de la le
mécanisme qui a été mis en oeuvre parle
par la jurisprudence est très
pragmatique
ils se sont pas focalisés sur la faute
normalement le régime de responsabilité
dans un commun or la responsabilité
contractuelle
c'est tout fait quelconque de l'homme et
ayant causé à autrui un dommage donc on
cherche la faute là il n'y a pas de foot
on est sur ses responsabilités
objectives comme les désordres en
garantie décennale on cherche pas à
savoir si l'entreprise le promoteur il
ya un désordre ça fuit ça coule dans la
maison la maison et plus on répare donc
la difficulté va venir sur
l'appréciation pas sur le respect d'un
règlement si on l'a tant mieux c'est
encore plus facile mais ça va être de
quoi souffrez vous et est ce que votre
souffrance est standard entre guillemets
ou est ce que vous vous êtes focalisé
sur le le fait que l'horloge du voisin
jouets westminter toutes les heures ce
qui est pas voilà
donc si on arrive à démontrer un critère
objectif delà de la souffrance ou en
tout cas une concrète aux
compréhensibles par la plupart des
personnes
on va y arriver il ya les exemples donc
ils font sourire mais du chant du coq
oui voilà bon le fameux effet avec chant
du coq acquis ou dans mon village on a
eu aussi la cloche il avait rétabli le
fait que l'horloge ce n'est toutes les
heures et où des menaces et ben voila
moi j'étais connu petit même la nuit
avec ça sonne elle admis en qualité en
plus ce moment un peu comme la chaussure
est ce qu'il est minuit et demi une
heure une heure et demie c'était en
passer son temps à ça ça pouvait
empêcher de dormir
bon eh ben on en est venu à encadrer les
horaires et à faire en sorte que
maintenant ça sonne je crois de 8 heures
jusqu'à 21h et que ça n'est plus ça
n'est plus une source de deux souvent
mais ça c'est même là où on pouvait lire
une histoire appréciation des gens qui
les disaient mais le village a toujours
été comme ça les coques vous voulez
interdir les cocas la campagne c'est des
trucs de parisiens vous êtes fous bon la
jurisprudence est quand même passé on
arrive au terme de cet entretien et de
ce rendez vous en direct qui devait vous
permettre d'avoir des réponses
éventuellement à vos questions de nous
faire part de vos commentaires sur les
conflits de voisinage et j'espère que
nous avons été d'une grande aide pendant
sept heures sur figaro live et sur la
chaîne figurent alive youtube avant de
conclure
jean philippe mariani si vous deviez
délivrer une ou deux astuces simples
pour pouvoir aider nos internautes à
désamorcer un conflit de voisinage qui
est en train de naître ou sur leur
nouveau lieu de vie où avec un nouveau
voisin qui vient d'arriver qu'est ce que
vous diriez n'écrivez pas parler oui
parler et essayer de trouver essayer de
valider un peu on parlait de coaching
mais essayer de bien travailler la mise
en relation la mise en relation est
essentiel et d'essayer de créer le
moment pour pouvoir en parler c'est vrai
qu'il faut pas forcément débarquer 21
ans il faut essayer de se dire vous
rendez vous en ce week-end on trouve un
moment et on essaye d'en parler c'est le
démarrage peut-être où on a le plus de
chance de de tuer le conflit dans l'oeuf
est de ne pas tuer son voisin outils
permettent alors de trevi sur touche à
sa fin merci encore de nous avoir suivis
en direct sur figaro l'avait sur youtube
merci pour vos commentaires et vos
questions merci beaucoup jean philippe
paré vous êtes je le rappelle l'expert
en droit immobilier et avocats
évidemment vous êtes donc avocat
spécialisé en droit immobilier pour être
plus juste
merci pour vos éclairages et evo et vos
commentaires et votre aide auprès des
internautes qui nous suivent à très
bientôt sur figaro live